oh boy it's been a busy time a lot of
stuff has happened
got myself a bad haircut I thought I'd
do an update vlog cuz there's a lot of
stuff I want to talk about so please sit
down and listen and shut the [ __ ] up we
did the cringe m'as live stream with
Ravel mode it was so much fun did you
watch it
let's do a highlight wait wait what to
be
[Applause]
and so we raised 1 million three hundred
over 1,300,000 dollars towards red which
is a charity-based to stop aids also
thanks to youtube who donated $100,000
and the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation which managed a million
dollars I'm very proud of that and I'm
proud of everyone involved but also we
gained a 50 million subscribers it
happened all at the same time at it was
so weird as Crazy's weekend Jesus Christ
50 million I know it's cliche as hell
for me to say this but I never thought
we would hit that number part of me is
like you know it's just a number really
all I care about is that you guys watch
my videos and that's what really matters
but at the same time 50 million [ __ ]
yeah
suck my dick em did I go fat it went
fast it happened at the same time as my
channel was dying thank God
think about that if your channel is
dying just pull the PR stunt and you're
you're fine again cuz it looks like now
you could fix my channel I don't know
what happened I want to talk about that
as well there was a lot that I wanted to
say in the video where I said I was
going to delete my channel or when I was
supposed to do it I didn't really get
the chance cuz I just that video needed
to be funny otherwise everyone would
kill me but basically would I delete my
channel have I thought about it so
you're in a serious way yes I have like
I said before it's just numbers and I
really do care about that you guys are
you guys just watch my videos that's the
main important thing for me I know it's
like a meme that YouTube is a job and
we're all just overpaid and we shouldn't
complain about anything which is true
I think being number one on YouTube or
being a youtuber in general it comes
with a price that is kind of hard to
explain without just sounding like oh
boo hoo your life is so hard
I don't think there's a point for me to
even get into it but it is true and a
lot of times I feel like it would be
nice to just be a normal channel you
know I have a huge amount of respect of
what for what I do I wouldn't just throw
that all the way lightly you know even
though we might not seem like it I
I really care about every single video I
make I make sure it's the best it can be
I do daily content after all so you know
there's only so much you can do with
that I take it very very seriously I
think a lot of people don't realize that
because I have this weird silly Swedish
guy persona where I'm just an idiot
which is also half true
you know it's an extension of my
personality just know why not talk about
like this I'm not really usually being
serious
which also seem like another thing that
people don't [ __ ] understand the main
thing about that a lot of people the
media especially didn't seem to
understand about the deletion video was
that I wasn't complaining just for me it
was a me just saying all YouTube I am
not making enough money [ __ ] you I
thought I was standing up for not just
myself but everyone else on the platform
because something clearly changed and
YouTube is is turning against it and we
can't really do much else but to raise
our voices about it people might say
okay well pretty PI's he's got a good
living what do you what do you think
YouTube is or do they just have the
right to screw everyone over I don't
think so I don't think they're they're
mean their intention is to do that by
the way my point was more like I need to
stand up for this this is an issue that
needs to be addressed but apparently I
can't do that without sounding like oh
ho to people that's that's how I took
the media's taking my response is really
stupid really
unresponsible I think I'm not the most
responsible as well so I probably
shouldn't talk so far I have not get
gone decent update or answer of what had
happened I haven't gotten gotten an
answer what is going on
no one has I think really gotten a
decent answer which I'm kind of
frustrated about I I know I'm gonna talk
to them soon again and I hope I will
have a better answer if anything there's
for you to learn from this is that they
need to have a better dialogue with
their users they need to have less just
specific dialogues with different
youtubers they need to talk to all of
YouTube it's not just the top guys
and if there's anything us youtubers
needs to learn or creators is that we
need to be more clear with what we're
saying
I think a lot of the rants or the
YouTube [ __ ] YouTube videos do they
really help I don't know
complaining about YouTube has just
become a meme I can imagine it's hard
for you to just see all these videos and
be like okay well what is really true
what is really just a rant and what is
really going on it seems so messy and I
think it's not gonna going anywhere I'm
just trying to criticize us really I
don't want to just [ __ ] on you whatever
YouTube's goal is I support it okay I'm
not trying to turn my back on it but I
do think if they talk to the users what
it is they will get there faster okay
just tell us talk to us I'm getting
tired of saying that now the media the
media's reaction to me delaying the
video was the absolute dumbest thing I
have ever seen and yet don't get me
wrong I don't hate the media not all
some motion bit okay most of it my
message got destroyed whatever I said in
that video they took whatever piece they
wanted from that and it was ridiculous I
made this other video that was very
articulate and very clear what the
problem was but no one talked about that
video they just took the first video I
did which was just like half satire half
comedy and they just took pieces out of
that and it was ridiculous so that's why
I really enjoyed that video where I
could make fun of them a little bit
because it was so stupid and to put it
in perspective we raised over a million
dollars to charity not a single one
posted about that not a single one of
those articles mentioned it even
mentioned it I think that says a lot I'm
not saying they're obligated to talk
about whatever we raise for charity but
it's interesting how it never even got
mentioned I think that just says a lot
about how media works you know too many
times I've been a punching bag
for the whole situate for what they're
doing anyway so I was glad how we turned
out I hope did you want me to delete my
channel are you disappointed now I am so
sorry
Oh boohoo booty pot and delete this
channel maybe you need another hobby
then I'm glad a lot of people were happy
that I wasn't deleting it at least I'm
really glad I don't have to answer the
question now what are you really gonna
do what poot are you really gonna do it
I also want to take the time to just say
thanks to everyone involved in the
cringe miss charity livestream with
rebel mode I want to thank Mark for
flying over and Amy it was really fun
hanging out with those guys a bit more
every time I meet mark I just meet him
for one day so I never really got a
chance to yet with him but it was really
fun I really enjoy it
jack and seeing them for flying over as
well of course so fun to meet those guys
just we had a great time of course PJ
we're helping out with the charity he's
a beautiful name with it don't like I
don't really like him though okay
kidding I had n Emma
of course apparently people were mean to
her in the comments so Emma don't listen
to anyone you're great you're so good
thanks for everyone that worked on the
charity and helped out it was it was I'm
really proud that we managed to hit our
donation goal and thanks to everyone
that donated it was amazing it was
really cool to see him that these are
the things cannot I'm really proud of
and I'm really happy that I'm able to do
these positive things with what I do now
moving forward what is gonna happen well
I'm not the leading well actually I am
at a hundred million we're deleting this
channel hundred million can we do it a
hundred million the haters better start
subscribing now cuz otherwise we'd run
out of people I feel like I'm barely
getting I'm just getting started I think
I will keep doing YouTube as long as I
feel like I have more to give and I
really feel like I still have that in me
I think that's the most important
important thing for me and I know Kasey
and I said recently stopped vlogging and
in a way I understand now why
because he said he wasn't because he was
tired he was more like creatively
exhausted I think doing the same thing
over and over it really wears you out
and and I think that's why you almost
it's almost like you get a different
PewDiePie each year
that's why I've changed so much because
that's how it's interesting and fun for
me and I really still enjoy it that way
so I'm not planning to go anyway but I
enjoyed the fact that you guys thought I
was it was cute other than that thank
you so much for supporting what I do it
really means the line especially when so
much I don't want to say hate but
negativity seems to be want to surround
what I do a lot of times despite the
fact that I don't think I do that much
bad okay
it's just how wet a psyche is so thank
you it means a lot it really does and
stay awesome I'll see you in the next
video roughest
[Music]